[Música]
queridos amigos y amigas cada dos por
tres nos encontramos con titulares y
noticias como estos Rusia la Corte Penal
Internacional emite una orden de arresto
contra Putin la Corte Penal
Internacional reanudará las
investigaciones de presuntos crímenes de
lesa humanidad en Venezuela el fiscal de
la Corte Penal Internacional Busca
acelerar la investigación contra
birmania por los rojillas y la pregunta
es sirven de algo los tribunales
internacionales han dado algún resultado
hasta la fecha realmente puede Vladimir
Putin terminar tras las rejas por una
sentencia emitida en la haya pues
queridos amigos en este vídeo vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
lo Primero lo primero saber dónde y cómo
empezó todo este tema de los tribunales
internacionales toca ver un poco de
historia pero antes solo un segundo
quieres estar al tanto de los
principales acontecimientos que influyen
en los mercados quieres saber más sobre
posibles crisis o sobre el estado de las
principales economías del mundo Pues no
te pierdas si lo hubiera sabido el canal
de información financiera de mutuactivos
con el que participamos por ejemplo
sabías que corremos el riesgo de sufrir
una gran crisis del Cobre cómo está
Japón escapando de su larga crisis o
hablando de Rusia como Putin está
logrando saltarse las sanciones
internacionales Pues todo esto y más lo
encontrarás en si lo hubiera sabido os
dejamos el enlace abajo en la
descripción y ahora sí arranquemos
[Música]
los primeros antecedentes
la Guerra de Ucrania ha sido uno de los
últimos casos que han hecho que la
justicia internacional se ponga las
pilas a comienzos del mes de julio de
2023 se puso en marcha formalmente esta
nueva iniciativa laia abre un centro
para investigar la guerra de Rusia en
Ucrania la Unión Europea dijo que el
centro tiene el objetivo final de
enjuiciar a los responsables de la
invasión de Ucrania el centro
internacional para el enjuiciamiento del
crimen de agresión incluye Fiscales de
Ucrania la Unión Europea Estados Unidos
y la Corte Penal Internacional La idea
es que este centro recopile pruebas y
prepare cargos contra los funcionarios
del kremlin no dejaremos piedras sin
remover para que Putin y sus secuaces
rindan cuentas ahora bien quizás penséis
que toda esta historia de la justicia
internacional es algo Bastante nuevo
pero lo cierto Es que no es así
[Música]
irónicamente fue la propia Rusia la que
comenzó a pensar en este tipo de
iniciativas hace ya más de 100 años en
1899 en la propia ciudad de la haya el
zar Nicolás II hizo una convocatoria
global para desarrollar
conferencia de paz con el fin de
establecer una modalidad de arbitraje
internacional que fuera capaz de Buscar
soluciones pacíficas a todos aquellos
problemas que podrían terminar
desencadenando una guerra Esto llevó a
la creación de la corte permanente de
arbitraje en la haya y vale Ya sé lo que
estaréis algunos pensando pero a ver
Alberto vaya birria No cómo que una
corte de arbitraje si apenas unos pocos
años después estalló la Primera Guerra
Mundial y Poco después la segunda vaya
fracaso No pues sí en cierto modo tenéis
toda la razón a la hora de evitar
guerras no fue particularmente útil al
final esta corte de arbitraje
básicamente se ciñó a resolver disputas
entre diferentes países sobre los
límites marítimos o la soberanía de
Islas por lo general asuntos
relativamente menores entre otras cosas
porque para que se cumplirán sus
disposiciones los países afectados
tenían que hacerlo voluntariamente Al
fin y al cabo no existe una policía
mundial que obliga a los países a
cumplir las sentencias de este organismo
Incluso si un país se negaba participar
en el proceso pues colorín Colorado el
cuento se había acabado ahora bien
quiere decir todo esto que la justicia
internacional no vale para nada
[Música]
pues ojo porque los 100 años que han
pasado desde la conferencia de paz
promovida por el zar Nicolás II no han
transcurrido en vano es posible que hoy
Vladimir Putin tenga algún motivo de más
del que preocuparse pero no nos
adelantemos amigos amigas la Primera
Guerra Mundial trajo consigo un nivel de
destrucción que hasta entonces parecía
impensable Quizás por eso por primera
vez en toda la historia en el tratado de
Versalles se establecieron tres
artículos que abrieron por primera vez
la posibilidad de juzgar a los Estados
agresores concretamente fueron los
artículos 227 29 y 30 Claro que al final
quedaron en nada hubo algunos juicios
pero no condenas los aliados optaron por
intentar superar lo antes posible las
tensiones con Alemania Así que no no
hubo responsables condenados por la
Primera Guerra Mundial o los crímenes de
guerra cometidos durante la contienda
pese a ello las tensiones no
desaparecieron y Poco después llegó el
nazismo y la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
ahí así todo fue diferente los crímenes
nazis fueron tan absolutamente atroces
que en 1945 se firmó el estatuto de
Londres del tribunal militar
internacional donde los aliados
acordaron los principios y los
procedimientos que regirían lo que más
tarde conocimos como juicios de
núremberg
[Música]
pero no vayamos tan rápido porque luego
llegó la guerra fría y claro es que
acaso iba a estar un tribunal
internacional investigando las acciones
represivas de las taxi en la Alemania
Oriental la intervención soviética en
Praga o la intervención norteamericana
en Vietnam pues evidentemente no y de
haberlo intentado eso Pues podría haber
terminado con la tercera guerra mundial
Así que lo que se hizo fue algo
diferente
por un lado en 1945 se creó la Corte
Internacional de Justicia para dirimir
disputas legales entre Estados y que en
cierto modo mantenía la naturaleza del
arbitraje lo que ya suponía una enorme
limitación Y es que veréis esta corta
internacional necesitaba que cuando se
diera un problema las partes implicadas
aceptaron acudir Y respetar la
jurisdicción de este organismo y claro
pues el problema estaba servido pensando
bien acaso un ladrón de bancos va a
aceptar de buena fe ser juzgado y acatar
libremente la sentencia evidentemente No
pues con los estados pasa tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo pero eso ni siquiera
es todo por otro lado la ONU acordó que
fuese En todo caso el Consejo de
Seguridad el organismo que tuviera la
potestad de deliberar y hacer cumplir
las resoluciones de este organismo en
Casos particularmente graves y como en
ese organismo tanto Estados Unidos como
la unión soviética tenían derecho de
veto Pues digamos que en la práctica
todo esto de la justicia internacional
sólo afectaba a cuestiones menores Y así
fue hasta que se produjo una nueva
guerra en Europa
para ello tenemos que dar un salto de
casi 50 años Estamos hablando por
supuesto de la guerra en la antigua
yugoslavia una guerra donde serbios
bosnios croatas se encontraban en una
lucha sin cuartel en la que abundaban
las denuncias sobre todo tipo de
crímenes la situación se puso tan fea
que en 1993 el Consejo de Seguridad
decidió crear el tribunal Penal
Internacional para la antigua yugoslavia
para perseguir precisamente los crímenes
de lesa humanidad además Poco después en
abril de 1994 estalló en Ruanda uno de
los conflictos étnicos más sangrientos
de la historia moderna el gobierno utu
asesinó sistemáticamente al 70% de la
población tutsi hablamos de cientos de
miles de víctimas y al igual que en el
caso de Bosnia Aquí también se creó un
tribunal Penal Internacional para Ruanda
al final en el caso de Bosnia se
enjuiciaron a 90 los funcionarios
civiles y militares mientras que en el
caso de Ruanda fueron 61 las personas
procesadas el coronel Irlandés y el
Primer Ministro del país durante la
masacre gingan banda terminaron tras las
rejas por su parte el presidente
yugoslavo esloboda milose vikiliber
serbio radoban karachi corrieron También
la misma suerte
y si durante el proceso estos organismos
tuvieron muchas limitaciones por ejemplo
en el caso de Bosnia el conflicto no
sólo continuó tras ponerse en marcha el
tribunal Penal Internacional para la
antigua yugoslavia sino que dos años más
tarde se registró la masacre de
celebrencha 8000 bosnios musulmanes
resultaron asesinados en una acción
realizada por fuerzas aliadas de Serbia
pero sea como sea en última instancia
una cosa quedó meridianamente Clara si
realmente se quería disuadir y castigar
crímenes había que superar todo ese tema
del arbitraje y hacía falta un organismo
que fuera permanente y no temporal como
los tribunales especiales para Ruanda y
Bosnia la justicia internacional
necesitaba una auténtica corte que fuese
capaz de llevar a cabo investigaciones y
procesos de forma unilateral y cuya
sentencias fuesen vinculantes Pues bien
para lograrlo en 1998 a instancias de
Naciones Unidas se aprobó el conocido
como estatuto de Roma a partir del cual
en el año 2002 comenzó a funcionar la
Corte Penal Internacional un organismo
que nació con una operativa
completamente diferente aunque el
Consejo de Seguridad o la asamblea de la
ONU puedan enviar casos a la corte la
fiscalía de este organismo por sí misma
puede iniciar automáticamente Y de forma
unilateral sus propias investigaciones
es decir ya no tenía que contar con la
aprobación de nadie ni de las partes
implica das ni de las grandes potencias
y del Consejo de Seguridad teóricamente
El Salto era galáctico ahora bien podrá
este organismo procesar a los jerarcas
rusos Pues bien veámoslo
camino sin salida
[Música]
todo esto de la justicia internacional
puede sonar muy bien pero sabéis que a
la hora de la verdad a muy pocos
gobiernos les gusta eso de que un
organismo internacional ande por ahí
husmeando en sus asuntos y desde luego
las grandes potencias son un buen
ejemplo Y eso es exactamente lo que
explica noticias como estas Rusia y
China beta en la medida de la ONU para
llevar a Siria a la Corte Penal
Internacional trampa autoriza sanciones
contra funcionarios de la Corte Penal
Internacional la última medida se
produce meses después de que la corte
autorizara una investigación sobre
presuntos crímenes de guerra cometidos
en Afganistán por las fuerzas
estadounidenses y afganas de hecho
aunque en el 98 la administración de
Bill Clinton fue muy activa a la hora de
promover el estatuto de Roma cuando
llegó la hora de ratificarlo la
Administración Bush decidió no hacerlo
los motivos el presidente norteamericano
lo dejó muy claro ustedes saben que
mientras Estados Unidos trabaja para
llevar la paz a todo el mundo nuestro
diplomáticos y soldados podrían ser
llevados ante este tribunal y eso es muy
preocupante para mí y por supuesto No
sólo fue Estados Unidos países como
Rusia India Israel o Turquía entre otros
muchos casos tampoco lo han firmado O
ratificado de hecho hoy por hoy el
estatuto de Roma solo está en vigor en
los países que habéis pintados en verde
es decir que la Corte Penal
Internacional existe pero hoy por hoy
ninguna gran potencia reconoce su
jurisdicción potencias que también
pueden impedir con su veto que el
Consejo de Seguridad le pida a la corte
investigar casos concretos que es la
opción que existe para llevar a cabo
procesos en países que no han ratificado
el tratado de Roma Esto es así porque
supuestamente los países miembros de la
ONU están obligados a cumplir con las
resoluciones del Consejo de Seguridad
pese a todo la corte funciona
actualmente la Corte Penal Internacional
tiene en marcha 17 investigaciones entre
las que destacan la persecución de
crímenes de guerra en la República
democrática del Congo uganda Libia y
Sudán así como delitos de lesa humanidad
en Afganistán Palestina y Venezuela en
varios de esos casos está corta llegado
a emitir órdenes de arresto
amigos la madre patria Rusia se enfrenta
a la Corte Penal Internacional no solo
en el caso de Ucrania sino también en lo
que respecta a los supuestos crímenes
cometidos durante su intervención
militar en Georgia en el año 2008 y la
pregunta la gran pregunta es hasta qué
punto tiene que preocuparle a Putin lo
que ocurra en la haya pues atento
el viaje aquí termina en la haya
queridos amigos de visualpolitik la
invasión a Ucrania tiene dos procesos
judiciales internacionales abiertos uno
en la Corte Internacional de Justicia
ante la cual Ucrania denunció a la
federación rusa el 26 de febrero de 2022
pidiendo amparar a los ciudadanos
ucranianos de un posible genocidio el 16
de marzo de 2022 esta corte dictaminó
que Rusia debía suspender inmediatamente
las operaciones militares Rusia por
supuesto hizo caso omiso Así que nada
que hacer por esa vía Por otra parte la
Corte Penal Internacional Recibió la
segunda denuncia aunque esta no provino
directamente del gobierno de bolo de
mirza lensky la primera semana de marzo
de 2022 El fiscal de la Corte Penal
Internacional Karim Khan recibió
múltiples peticiones de los gobiernos de
lituania Albania Australia Austria
Colombia Costa Rica y Finlandia entre
otros países para iniciar una
investigación sobre lo que estaba
aconteciendo en Ucrania esta
investigación sin embargo está
resultando muy particular además de
poner el foco en Putin también se
investiga el rol de María alexeina loba
belova comisionada por los derechos del
niño en la oficina del presidente de la
federación rusa se les acusa a ambos de
ser los autores intelectuales de la
deportación ilegal de niños desde las
zonas ocupadas de Ucrania a la
federación rusa
Moscú dice que 700.000 niños de la zona
de conflicto de Ucrania ahora están en
Rusia Pero por qué se está investigando
a Rusia este país no ha ratificado el
estatuto de Roma
[Música]
Pues porque aunque Rusia no lo hizo
Ucrania que es el país perjudicado
Aunque todavía no lo ha ratificado sí
que lo firmó y además aceptó
explícitamente la jurisdicción de este
organismo en relación con los crímenes
cometidos en su territorio desde 2014 y
eso permite que las investigaciones
puedan continuar y es lo que explica la
noticia que veíamos al principio de este
vídeo 17 de marzo del 2023 Rusia la
Corte Penal Internacional emite una
orden de arresto contra Putin ahora bien
puede prosperar esta acusación Pues por
ahora las posibilidades parecen pocas
[Música]
Rusia no reconoce la jurisdicción de la
Corte Penal Internacional y este
organismo no tiene la capacidad de hacer
cumplir sus disposiciones en general
hasta ahora las grandes potencias han
sido totalmente indiferentes a todos
estos tribunales internacionales sin
tener que asumir ningún coste podemos
hablar de las acusaciones contra Estados
Unidos por su intervención Afganistán o
en Irak de la toma China de Hong Kong o
ahora de la Guerra de Ucrania y Claro
sin el apoyo de Estados Unidos ya os
imaginaréis que las capacidades reales
de este organismo son muy limitadas pese
a ello en el caso de Putin los
tribunales internacionales ya están
recabando activamente pruebas sobre la
violación de Derechos Humanos en Ucrania
digamos que en algún lugar de los Países
Bajos hay un gabinete lleno de
documentos que podrían complicar la
impunidad de la camarilla que hoy maneja
el kremlin si mañana cambias el
liderazgo en Rusia Putin podría verse en
una situación muy comprometida porque
básicamente no tendría tan fácil
encontrar Refugio entre otras cosas
porque tendrá órdenes internacionales de
arresto cursadas en su contra Nada es
imposible pero milose Beach y vagossora
actuaron con la misma impunidad en su
momento y al final terminaron entre
rejas pero por ahora no parece que eso
sea particularmente probable
en cualquier caso llegas hasta aquí nos
asalta Una última pregunta realmente
sirve para algo la Corte Penal
Internacional pues lo cierto Es que
aunque no esté siendo el organismo más
importante del mundo sí que está
sirviendo para dos cosas primero para
perseguir a ciertos dictadorzuelos
particularmente sangrientos Aunque
actualmente la corte solo mantiene a
siete personas bajo custodia con juicios
en marcha entre ellos se encuentran Ali
muhamed Ali app de rachmann jefe de
milicias armadas utanesas acusado de
perpetrar 31 crímenes de guerra en el
conflicto armado que ataña dicho país o
Bosco taganda líder guerrillero con
goles también con una docena de crímenes
de guerra encima eso es mejor que nada
Por otra parte la corta contribuido a
denunciar los comportamientos excesivos
de ciertos gobiernos el caso de Putin es
un buen ejemplo pero también lo es este
otro la Corte Penal Internacional
investigadora Venezuela por crímenes de
lesa humanidad la fiscalía de la haya
dirigirá ejecuciones extrajudiciales
detenciones arbitrarias y torturas
cometidas bajo el gobierno de maduro
Corte Penal Internacional recibe más de
2.000 testimonios de víctimas sobre
investigación por crímenes de lesa
humanidad en Venezuela pero llegamos
hasta aquí ahora sí que sí el turno es
para ti qué te parece la existencia de
tribunales de Justicia internacionales
crees que deberían reforzarse terminará
Putin procesado y entre rejas déjanos
tus impresiones en los comentarios y
hablamos debate Muchas gracias por estar
ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]